[Music]
thank you
Time Keeps On Slipping like sand through
my hands
I honestly can't believe I'm as old as I
am the moon keeps on pulling the tides
of this water but who would have thought
we'd have a blue-eyed daughter oh
thank you
[Music]
the footsteps behind us keep washing
away
the shape of the shoreline seems
addicted to change a blink of an eye
another
flies by
isn't it a wonder that we're even alive
breathing
foreign
[Music]
Story Goes On
beautiful miracle
Sun
and the Sun
[Music]
last night I drove four hours today I
have four hours on the clock and the day
before that I drove four hours
um so this was a lot of unexpected
driving there was a lot of snow moving
in and the temperatures were dropping
down to like single digits this week
so I decided to head south I'm running
into a lot of wind like crazy crazy wind
it's been knocked over into the other
lane
um which is really scary and it was
actually not so bad driving at night
because there's like no other cars on
the road less intimidating than driving
today where there are other cars it is
so windy
foreign
[Music]
it can be sad sometimes
roaming around out here all alone
the low moments especially but the high
ones too
because even though the moment is
beautiful all on its own
it would be even better to share with
someone
I know that day will eventually come
but for now these long stretches of
Solitude
especially over this past year have
taught me so much about myself
they've created the time and space to
confront so many of my own self-limiting
beliefs and unhelpful patterns while
also teaching me to just be at home with
myself
during both the good times and the bad
Solitude has a way of inviting emotions
to the surface and
I've been learning to embrace those
emotions sit with them and then let them
go one by one
the plan was just to come out here work
and catch up on video editing and chill
campsite good internet all the things
but last night even though this was not
in the forecast at all it just started
thunderstorming out of nowhere like
crazy lightning and thunder and just
pouring rain and then started hailing
and I was like what is happening so cold
inside the van I literally like eat
gloves my heater is not working because
there's no uh Power my battery's dead if
you have a cloudy day and you're not
moving the van it's like I don't have
enough solar panels or batteries to
really keep it going when I'm doing
heavy video editing and stuff so anyway
I have decided to push away all my
responsibilities and go Adventure
thank you
[Music]
creating these videos actually is an
area where I've long struggled with fear
and sharing them was something I wanted
to do long before I ever found the
courage to try
I actually started this YouTube channel
back in 2015.
I posted one video and then managed to
avoid posting a new one for another four
years
when I finally did it was my van tour
video and it went viral and I was so
Frozen by my own self-expectation to
create something just as good if not
better that I avoided posting again for
another four months
even as a photographer I've known that
video is what I'm most excited to create
when Instagram stories first launched
around seven years ago I spent hours
creating short vertical videos that
would fit the 15 second mold
back then you couldn't use mainstream
music like we can today but I didn't
know what else to use so I tried anyway
Instagram began flagging my content to
the point where I was warned my entire
account would be deleted if I posted any
more music
I remember when I read that email and
just felt all my creativity wash out to
see like what was the point in Sinking
so much time and effort into something
that I was ultimately being punished for
I felt the same way about YouTube videos
because all of a sudden my channel was
eligible for monetization and I had to
work out how to license music for
commercial use
it's easy to say now that it was all
figure outable
but at that time it felt like a
Monumental obstacle the fear took hold
and my drive to create all but
disappeared
[Music]
then a few years ago I saw a sponsored
segment for a music platform by a
filmmaker I really admire after browsing
through a few playlists I felt inspired
to create again
so I'm really excited to share them as
today's sponsor musicbed
music is an essential part of my
creative process and oftentimes the
inspiration behind entire Concepts what
sets musicbed apart is the quality of
work it represents and the way that each
song becomes a key ingredient that
starts to elevate the final output this
video for example was meant to be a
light-hearted camping story but while
editing I stumbled across this song that
unexpectedly tapped into some
unexpressed emotion around my
grandfather's passing a completely new
dialogue emerged and the whole video was
transformed into something that I will
always look back on and treasure
you can check out my personal playlist
if you're interested in browsing some of
the songs that I love and you can hear
the difference yourself when you sign up
for a free account and use code C
Schaefer at checkout to receive one
month free when you purchase an annual
subscription thanks again to musicpad
for sponsoring this video
oh that's cool
foreign
was quiet
he was at home with the Silence of the
desert and he was content just to look
at the trees
he still had a long way to go to reach
the pyramids
and someday this morning would be just a
memory
this was the present moment
my hands get so dry in these high desert
environments my table starts to warp
typically by April my table will be like
this and the only thing that will fix it
is getting back into Coastal environment
last night my water pump stopped working
which
is a bummer it's
toast it's like
NADA first I checked the fuse box uh for
the water pump made sure that was intact
turned the master power switch off and
toggled the water pump switch on and off
and nothing was working so I also
checked underneath the sink and back
here to make sure there weren't any
leaks not seeing anything so my guess is
the water pump needs to be replaced
which
I have no idea what I'm doing but I'm
gonna have to try to figure that out
so I have this water tank down here
and yeah just back to the old SUV
methods
of uh
putting water into my Nalgene
all right so here's the situation uh
I'm gonna try to replace my water pump
because it stopped working I have no
clue what I'm doing literally none I am
still in my PJs and I did not feel like
getting ready so this is what you're
gonna get today
I got the cabinet door off
it's it's hard to work in such a small
space I've just got crap everywhere I'm
gonna give this a go and try not to get
electrocuted okay I turned the power off
power so now what dismantling
maybe I bet you a bunch of water's about
to come out
yep that's a lot of water I have removed
but it's not fudging triage
oh we need to figure out
the wiring
which is very intimidating here's a
situation friends these are the two
wires
oh no they go back there
it just gets more complicated ah so I
just took this plate off
and
we'll see if we can access things
behind here
okay I have connected the new one and
before I install everything I'm going to
put the fuse back in and turn the power
back on and just see if it works if it
does then we can go ahead and finish the
installation oh it works okay Okay
cool so we're gonna finish the
installation we're gonna turn this off
again
so here we go
come on there you can do and do it this
is where having power tools would be so
handy I gotta get some Power Tools in my
life I need to tape up
[Music]
and out
you know what
screw this one
screw this screw but we don't need it
where's the electrical tape I don't know
if I'm doing this right just hoping for
the best
that's how we do things around here
I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know
I do not know who even invents this
stuff I'm so fascinated by this whole
world and I know nothing about for some
reason I just have these nonsensical
limitations that I place on myself that
I'm like oh I don't do that I don't know
how to do that and that's just a fact
that's how I felt with the guitar and
then I just started slowly learning and
I mean slowly and now I'm starting to
get to the point where I really look
forward to playing every day because my
fingers don't hurt everything just takes
time and patience and curiosity and like
willingness to learn being on my own has
really kind of pushed me out of my
comfort zone in that way and I've spent
so much of my life being on my own and
going off and doing new things and like
moved overseas on my own I moved out to
Hawaii on my own I
I did a lot of things on my own so I
have that in me but it's kind of like a
muscle if you don't keep it strong it
will atrophy over time
and it's like I forgot how capable I am
and it's just really empowering is what
I'm trying to say but I have yet to turn
this water pump on maybe I'm speaking
too soon I guess this is the moment of
truth
oh water's coming up
leaking right there
dang it
[Music]
the raindrops are singing on a roof mate
10.
Melodies in tune with the sound of the
wind no matter how long our song goes on
isn't it a one this little love came
along
[Music]
oh
it's a beautiful miracle
that we're even alive
[Music]
beautiful miracle
you and I
[Music]
it's a beautiful miracle
Story Goes On
beautiful miracle
[Music]
and the Sun
we're back in business
foreign